I'm at Sydney Uni today this is the
place where I learned to be a teacher so
it seemed like an appropriate place to
make a special announcement I've started
a second channel and it helping others
learn to be teachers it's a channel with
the purpose of aiding teachers to become
better at what they do
I'm really happy to be starting this for
lots of reasons but let me just tell you
- first I know that many of you watching
now are teachers and I know how hard
your job is you've so many worthwhile
things to do and people to care for but
you show a little time to do it you need
all the support you can get and I'm by
no means of have a teacher or a master
at everything I do
but I have got some experiences worth
sharing and I've certainly made enough
mistakes to learn quite a lot from them
life's too short to learn from only your
own mistakes we all need to lean on
others and learn from theirs - so to the
teachers out there I hope you'll find
the conference talk flogs resources book
reviews and other stuff on the new
channel useful but secondly I hope lots
of you who are still students will watch
- I started this channel for students
and we're surprised that teachers found
it helpful as well if you're a student
even if the new channel isn't aimed at
you I hope you'll enjoy having a kind of
behind-the-scenes look at how it teaches
brain works and what kind of thinking
and discussion us teaches to you before
we actually get into the classroom and
teach if you're interested you can check
out the trailer for the new channel here
and there's also a link to it in the
description have a good one